happy star wars Friday everybody we have
to talk all about emperor palpatine's
secret contingency plan should he die
we actually got some brand-new
information
welcome young skywalker, i have been expecting you.
i'm looking forward to completing your training. in time
you will hold me master.
there's a brand new novel called empires end
then that informs all of this backstory
and what's going on during the last Jedi
and may have offered some clues about the
origins of supreme leader Snoke being
beyond our own galaxy so if you're new
to the channel i do Star Wars videos
every week be sure to subscribe to get
everything i'm even doing a special
giveaway that i'll explain at the end of
the video if you haven't been reading
the books since disney bought Star Wars a
couple years ago since force awakens
came out there about four books that
take place between the events of Return
of the Jedi and the force awakens that
inform what's going on, answer a whole
bunch of the questions about character
motivations backstory and this new
secret Palpatine contingency plan
most of the time we spent with Emperor
Palpatine is actually during the
prequels we learn a little bit about
what he's thinking inside his head
during the original trilogy he's
really.just commanding the police trying
to turn Luke Skywalker there's very
little about his imagination that you
actually learn about is the tragedy of
Darth Plagueis the life
no I thought
on the story the Jedi would tell you
it's a fifth legend Darth Plagueis the
Dark Lord of the Sith so powerful and so
why he could use the Force to influence
the midi-chlorians to create life he had
such a knowledge of the dark side he
could even keep the ones he cared about
from dying it's really only in the
aftermath book series that you learn
about his obsession with what's going on
beyond the galaxy he still very obsessed
with the dark side of the force
so what he does is the Horde artifacts
in installations all over the galaxy
trying to map the unknown region because
he believes the origins of the force are
somewhere beyond the balance of our
galaxy in the Unknown Regions is one of
the most dangerous places to try and go
that's why it's called the Unknown
Regions because it's been so hard to map
they refer to it affectionately is a
labyrinth of solar storm rogue magneto
spheres black hole's gravity wells and
things far stranger so I know you're
like wait a minute what does that mean
far stranger what's going on in the
outer rim the Emperor wasn't the only
one that was obsessed with the Unknown
Regions the Jedi had long used the
planet illume which is in the Unknown
Regions is a source of Kyber crystal for
their lightsabers so they would send
younglings out on the crucible ship
during clone wars to go look for them
the force make physical a Jedi is
comes great responsibility with that yes
protect others how does a Jedi you know
you're my favorite you shall but first
harvest your crystal each one of you
must many things i am on this ship
teaching me and I before you but i will
continue teaching and you don't have to
you call me what you want but it's
sci-fi memory banks I contain a record
of every life say that ever made and the
Jedi who fashioned which we use super
grip because of approach what enables
opposed to the countries in whale by
Stephen Ward black if you didn't tell
that was actually David Tennant that
played that droid he was actually a big
character on clone work that's all still
cannon so Emperor Palpatine knows about
this but he feels like there's even more
to be learned in gain from going beyond
our galaxy in finding another galaxy
that's free from all the crap that's
been happening with the Jedi free from
all the turmoil so he wants a fresh
start with the remnants of his empire so
one of his many contingency plans should
he die is that he has a plan in place
where the remnants of the Empire to go
start a new somewhere else with trusted
advisors in New strong foundation on the
dark side of the force but like all
empires not everybody agrees about this
so you have this really curious area of
space that's really dangerous and hard
to traverse so the Emperor just
continues to send expeditions out to try
and find things find a way through it so
that they can go to another galaxy but
eventually they discover some ancient
computational mechanism that allows them
to safely traverse through so the
Emperor set his plan in motion should he
died at the Battle of Endor I know it
sounds crazy that the Emperor someone
that powerful in the dark side of the
force would actually believe that he was
capable of death with all that prequel
talk about Darth Plagueis being able to
survive debt so that gets into the
wheels obviously people learn how to
make force ghost the living force
becomes a really big thing but our books
like dark Empire where he actually does
have secret clones hidden in the décor
on this where he becomes a clone of
himself
it was a really
story but that's all part of Star Wars
legends so technically it's not canon so
you can't really take into account so
all of this Unknown Regions first-order
origins going beyond the galaxy stuff is
still cannon because it appears in the
new books the epic part 1 of this plan
is to lure the remnants of the
rebellions fleet to the planet jakku
where the Empire has this secret base
called the observatory is one of
Palpatine's secret installations where
he's been hoarding things so Palpatine
choose a successor gallius Rex's big
person in the aftermath series he's the
leader of the Imperial fleet but he also
has another chosen successor who is a
dark side for force cultist called tashu
remember she died he wants the new
empire that will form in his wake to be
founded on the dark side of the force
so they're going to lure the rest of the
rebellion to the planet jakku in
detonate a very special box that will
blow up the planet in the rest of the
rebel fleet with it
the problem is is that another Imperial
officer named Rae Sloane that they
introduced during rebels he's been in
the comic book series who's been
following galius Rex's orders doing all
this dirty work for him sees that he
plans to detonate this bomb on jakku and
he'll kill a bunch of Imperials with it
he just thinks that he's going to be the
worst person ever to lead the new empire
that's going to form so she kills him in
what ends up happening is the rebels
defeat the Imperial fleet the Super Star
Destroyer that they're on crashes to the
planet and that's what you saw in that
very first Star Wars The Force awakens
trailer that Rey is scavenging parts
from sort of like a tomb for the
remnants of the empire
But least to say the bomb never goes off so
the planet Jakku never blows up because
Rey's there at the beginning of force
awakens what happens is this new Rae
Sloan character become supreme leader
effectively and takes them with their
special new star charts that they
discovered into the Unknown Regions
where they begin to form of the first
order what happens next is that the
Imperials build their strength in the
first-order slowly starts to form in the
Unknown Regions beyond our galaxy
supreme leader Snoke only arrives when
they come back in full force
he didn't come from our galaxy so what
happened is that there's this mystery
missing period of time when Ray's Sloan
took the remnants of the fleet beyond
our galaxy that we don't know about yet
snow comes back with them
there's all this political
back-channeling black-market dealing
where they begin to fund the creation of
the Starkiller base in that leads us to
the beginning of force awakens the
really interesting thing about this is
that star wars hasn't dealt too much
with things happening outside the galaxy
itself to use along with a race of
beings Luke Skywalker's disciples spot
in the legends books the now legends
books it's not canon anymore but there
are a lot of creatures that live beyond
our galaxy so it makes sense that other
galaxies are just as bio diverse is our
own galaxy and star wars so that's not
the race that snow comes from but it
just helps support the claim that
Emperor Palpatine was correct when he
assumed that the nature of the force
came from something beyond our own
galaxy it's not just all completely
localized our galaxy to be a very
egocentric view of the force
let me know in the comments what do you
think about the idea of smoke being
someone from beyond our own galaxy
it would certainly explain how he was
not around during the events of the
original trilogy during the prequels but
he is also for sensitive so there's a
whole bunch more backstory they reveal
in this Empires End book so i recommend
you check it out but i'll continue to do
bonus videos about it, you just learn all
kinds of really awesome things about the
characters between return of the jedi in
the modern films so it's going to be a
lot of fun to take through it so i'll
continue that on my star wars friday
next week but because the Rogue one DVD
is coming out that's what the giveaway
is going to be for now so
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
i'll announce the winner the next time
I post a star wars video. so what's going
to happen later today is there's some
really cool injustice footage to drop
that i'll do a trailer video for there's
some cool Deadpool news about him
spinning off the x-force movies so I'll
trying to get to that as fast as
possible thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five
while you wait for that to post you can
click here to learn about Leia's backstory
with supreme leader Snoke and you
can click here to learn all about what's
going on with the brand new Nightwing Movie
that's coming!